hi everyone chrissy teigen is stepping
back
into the public eye to encourage people
to vote in the 2020
presidential election hi
i want to do a special song that i
dedicated to my wife a little while ago
i wrote this song as a tribute to our
relationship and the fact that love can
get us through
all kinds of tough times and we know
that the whole nation is going through
tough times right now
on monday chrissy's hubby john legend
performed at a philadelphia rally in
support of democratic presidential
nominee joe biden
and senator kamala harris and he invited
chrissy her mom and their two kiddos
four-year-old luna and two-year-old
miles to the stage
i want to send a shout out actually can
you come on stage maybe
i want you guys to see my wife is here
am i
my daughter luna's here
my son miles is here we're teaching our
young people early that
got to participate in their democracy
we're here to save democracy
all of us are here together to save
democracy right
chrissy shared a few moments from their
trip to philly on
instagram including their hotel view
their motorcade to the event a quiet
moment backstage
a snippet from john's performance and
naturally a hilarious beauty shot of the
philly cheesesteak they ordered at the
end of the night
this is a lot to cut maybe cut it in
half a little
the night marked chrissy's first public
appearance since the loss of her and
john's third child
a son named jack in september at the
time the cookbook author took a few
weeks off of social media
and returned after penning an emotional
essay about the pain she and her family
endured
after their loss where she wrote in part
quote
i feel bad our grief was so public
because i made the joy so public
i was so positive it would be okay i
feel bad that i made you all feel bad
i always will on halloween the 34 year
old debuted a touching tribute to jack
date night while having a date night
with her grammy winner hubby
chrissy shared this pic of the couple
holding hands
revealing a tattoo of jack's name
written in cursive on her wrist
and on monday chrissy who had previously
shared that she needed to undergo blood
transfusions while
in the hospital took to twitter to share
the sweet way her friends paid tribute
to jack
quote i have the absolute best friends
in the world
a small circle but if it were 50 times
larger i still wouldn't feel the love i
do
every day seven bags donated for the
seven used for jack
love you so much